Very important,
friends,
share massively and
please like the video.
1 very important information to share with you
1 time you have 3 months of presence here in France,
the 1st thing you should look for,
is to create 1 bank account.
1 bank account.
You must
have this bank account there,
why you must have this bank account there,
to begin with,
is to demonstrate,
This is part of the evidence that shows
your arrival.
And we need proof.
You know that we are in 1 country where everything is justified
by evidence,
1 bank account,
you must have as soon as you arrive,
because there are many who have written to me in common,
in inbox,
who wants,
who are there for 3 months,
4 months,
and who don't know where to start.
1 bank account to start.
The second thing is medical help.
You get this
1 time you have your passport,
go to the bank and create this account,
okay?
Now the vital card too,
folks,
Mr. E,
because the vital card,
is for those who have their documents,
the M. E,
especially the M E,
the small K of the State which is dedicated to the undocumented.
You must also do this process,
how you should have
this image,
I have already explained in my previous video.
So go back to my page and watch the video,
because on my videos,
I always mark how.
Obtain the M E
how to create a bank account
especially for those who are not in a situation
so regular friends.
Follow the videos,
share,
like please.